economía en directo América de Francia
24 Daniela Blandón con nosotros en el
estudio Daniela vamos a hablar de un
tema específico hablamos de Colombia y
Venezuela que reanudaron digamos
técnicamente las relaciones bilaterales
pero que da mucho camino por recorrer
Así es de Raúl pues estos dos países
dieron ya un primer paso hacia la
normalización de relaciones diplomáticas
y comerciales el 26 de septiembre
reabrieron el paso a transporte de carga
después de años de relaciones congeladas
pero el paso peatonal sigue restringido
en ciertos horarios y el de vehículos
particulares está prohibido Además él se
anunció una reanudación de vuelos que no
ha ocurrido un equipo de Francia 24
estuvo en la frontera y esto descubrimos
Anahí delgado es colombiana Perú ha
vivido la mayoría de sus 68 años en
Venezuela
[Música]
desde hace siete años tras el cierre de
la frontera entre ambos países saca
provecho de la crisis para
vengo a comprar las colchitas aquí
porque tengo una bodeguita tengo una
bodega vendo vendo esto
arrocito harina esto
galletitas chucherías chucherías porque
en Venezuela no hay nada de aquí llevan
para allá Y allá está mucho carro todo
que lo que la mayoría vende muy caros el
gobierno venezolano de Nicolás maduro y
el colombiano de Gustavo Petro también
de izquierda acordaron retomar una
política de puertas abiertas Y aunque
por ahora la reapertura se limita al
paso de carga y de vuelos en cientos de
locales comerciales como este se
encendió una luz de esperanza lo que
queremos es que vuelva toda la
normalidad pues buena ventas donde se
haya fluido de gente ya que pues es un
año la cuarta parte de lo que era la
parada antes antes habían puestos de
horas ambulantes en todo esto
camiones con insumos médicos y productos
de aseo fueron los primeros en cruzar la
frontera en un acto simbólico el 26 de
septiembre
Kevin María Sandra Guzmán administra una
de las agencias aduaneras que logró
gestionar el primer envío a Venezuela
tras la reapertura fueron ocho empresas
que creyeron en nosotros
negociaciones formales legales con pagos
al exterior con toda la operación como
debe ser se exportaron cartón corrugado
dulce confitería vasos desechables se
desportó papel higiénico para el 2015 en
Cúcuta existían 68 empresas aduaneras
Ahora solo quedan cinco yo creo que ya
los ojos están derretidos De tanto
llorar de la alegría de la emoción de
saber que que podemos volver a arrancar
siendo legales y competitivos en esta
región
un nuevo comienzo cargado de retos entre
ellos convencer de legalizarse a los
comerciantes que usan diariamente los
más de 170 caminos ilegales conocidos
Como trochas que se han multiplicado
desde que comenzó la crisis diplomática
lo que sí hay Daniela es más dudas que
certezas entre los productores
colombianos Así es Raúl pues este paso
de camiones por el puente internacional
Simón Bolívar que vimos el 26 de
septiembre fue un acto simbólico pero
todavía queda mucho camino por el
momento se sabe que los productos que
Irán de Venezuela a Colombia van desde
aluminio hasta acero carbón y café
procesado mientras que los primeros
envíos desde Colombia incluyeron
elementos de aseo confitería cartón y
plástico también hasta el momento ni los
mandatarios ni otros funcionarios de
ambas naciones han dado suficientes
detalles sobre cómo será el tránsito de
camiones en adelante ni tampoco Cuáles
Serán las regulaciones sobre el
intercambio comercial pero los gobiernos
siguen Claro que sí por qué Porque en su
mejor momento el comercio binacional por
ejemplo en 2008 cuando las relaciones
eran buenas fue de 7.200 millones de
dólares ahora se espera que a corto
plazo llegue al menos a 4 mil millones
de dólares anuales y que en 2027 y de
ahí en adelante pueda inclusive superar
los 8.000 millones de dólares pero para
muchos todavía reina la incertidumbre y
no solamente porque todavía no se ha
dicho cuando se va a permitir la libre
circulación peatonal y el cruce de
vehículos particulares sino también
porque se anunció que el 26 de
septiembre se reabriría la frontera
aérea Y eso todavía no ha sucedido
Dani como siempre Gracias por toda la
información nos vemos en una próxima
oportunidad